les ambulanciers hospitaliers sont en
grève il dénonce un manque de
reconnaissance et un statut inadapté des
manifestations sont organisées un peu
partout en france à paris rassemblement
devant le ministère de la santé
rassemblement cas suivi notre reporter
qui est technique
aujourd'hui les ambulanciers demander la
reconnaissance du statut aux deux
soignants car il effectue de nombreux
gestes médicaux en intervention alors
dans cette revendication ils sont
souvent soutenus par leur direction par
les agences régionales de santé et même
par leurs députés locaux mais rien
n'avance c'est pourquoi ils sont passés
à la mobilisation nationale la grève
aujourd'hui avec un rassemblement devant
le ministère de la santé à paris à
l'appel de la cgt de fo et de sud cette
mobilisation a été suivie car il est
entre 2500 et 3000 ambulanciers dans le
service public en france il y avait
plusieurs centaines d'ambulanciers ici
ils ont également été rejoint par
thierry qu bury ambulanciers ou chu de
toulouse qui a décidé de rejoindre paris
à vélo tout en passant par poitiers une
étape la semaine dernière est toujours
pour rendre visible cette revendication
du statut de soignants alors aujourd'hui
il ya eu des concerts de klaxons de
sirène avec les différentes ambulance
qui s'arrêtait à proximité de la
mobilisation de nombreux fumigènes des
pétards on entendait également des
chants olivier on est là et concernant
ses revendications je vous propose
d'écouter deux ambulanciers de
l'association française des ambulanciers
smur et hospitaliers petit à petit on
attendait autre chose seulement le
gouvernement s'est appuyé là dessus pour
ne pas vouloir valoriser tout simplement
nos professions parce que les caractères
induit à cette revalorisation ne
représentait pas le niveau du bac alors
que bon ça fait sourire un peu parce que
de nombreux ambulanciers sur le
territoire national aujourd'hui sont
déjà titulaires du baccalauréat et voir
plus parce que certains ont même fait ni
d'universitaires qu'on en a marre d'être
tout le temps d'avoir une étiquette de
conducteurs dans le dos
les gens ils nous voyaient toutes nos
salles le conducteur est chauffeur donc
ces mots clés de la dans le camp de la
fonction publique et qu'il faudrait
inconnu mano ministère de le bannir et
ensuite c'est tout simplement on n'est
pas à considérer au contact du patient
voilà donc je sais pas pourquoi alors
que malgré qu'on conduit effectivement
bien on est là aussi pour porter secours
on est là pour les massages cardiaques
on est là pour aider les fermiers à
préparer à une perfusion a préparé un
électrocardiogramme à mettre en place le
plateau d'incubation voilà et est donc
qu on nous dit qu'on n'est pas en
contact du patient donc il ya un truc
qu'on ne comprend pas alors que naît de
soignants aux urgences et un brancardier
lui il est considéré et pas nous une
délégation a été reçue durant 15 minutes
ministère de la santé les ambulanciers
sont en première ligne bien sûr depuis
le début de l'épidémie et ils ont été
les oubliés du ségur alors ils
continueront à mettre la pression ils
seront reçus de nouveau pour une réunion
aux bonne et due forme au ministère de
la santé dans quinze jours